it was amazing to be able to wake up
with them and go to sleep with them be
able to feed them and catch all the
little things first like their first big
old first time they reach for something
and grabbed it my name is Nicole Helen
I'm 29
when I look at my baby I just feel
happiness but I feel sadness at the same
time because I feel that I shouldn't be
out of my other children's lives
second time around I understand it this
is a blessing to be able to sit here and
do time for a mistake that I made and
still be able to have my pride and Joy's
with me
the room has given me the opportunity to
learn how to change myself in the way
that I think about things and that there
are consequences with every action that
you do
you